so here is an equally amazing but much
happier story so a few days ago in Iowa
an 83 year old man was driving with his
dog to go ice fishing he had a fishing
shack out on the lake then the man's
Jeep fell through the ice and into the
lake several Rescuers jumped into action
because Iowa was an extremely nice State
and one of The Rescuers was a 17 year
old high school student called Joseph
salmon he was ice fishing with his mom
when he saw the Jeep go under he was
able to help save the man and his dog
and so we wanted to talk to him tonight
and we are Joseph salmon joins us
tonight Joseph thank you so much for
coming on
few things scarier than someone going
under the ice how did you help get this
man and his dog out
so as soon as I seen him go into the
water I turned around and yelled at my
mom and told her he went through and I
had no one ready to dial because as I
seen him going over there I see him go
through as I was running I called 9-1-1
call 9-1-1 ran over there and for a
second we just were I was standing on
the shoreline and another guy came down
we were like waving at him tell him like
trying to tell him get out get out of
the Jeep and he was kind of in shock
didn't really know what to do he just
kind of sit in there
and as we were waving up more people
came down and one of the guys said
there's a child in the Jeep
and as soon as someone said there's a
child I got everything I needed off my
first layer and I jumped into the water
got to the Jeep tried opening the back
door which was it was locked it would
not open and I broke the back window
you went into the well this is a little
more dramatic than it was you went into
the water in a frozen lake and smashed
the back window
that's amazing how did you get was there
a child in the Jeep and how did you get
the man and his dog out
so after I broke the back window I used
a knife to break the back window and he
was when I broke as I was breaking the
back window he was getting out of his
seat and he started to crawl through the
back and he got his foot was stuck
between the Center Council and the seat
so I went all the way into the Jeep into
the front of it pulled his leg out
pushed on the bottom of it to like push
him up and I crawled back out to like
get have more room for them to come and
as he was coming between the seat and
the roof of the Jeep he was it's very
it's not a very big gap and he couldn't
get through that so I went back in the
Jeep I pushed him back towards the front
and pushed him up so on a Jeep back seat
there's like a lever on top of it a full
deceit down
so I pushed them back I flipped the seat
down and grabbed them by under his
shoulders and started pulling them out
how old are you
17.
that's just an absolutely crazy story I
don't think one in a hundred a thousand
people would get into a car going under
a frozen lake I mean that is just that
is heroism and I appreciate your coming
on and telling us about it tonight
Joseph salmon thank you you're welcome
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight